welcome to the recruitment rollercoaster
podcast my name is Hisham Aziz today I'm
in London I'm joined by Tom
ennifer who works for business called
cobalt recruitment who specialized in
real estate in construction and Tom's
worked at this business for just over
five years
it's a now way managing consultant
managing a team of four great thanks for
joining me pleasure thanks John so yeah
I think I actually got a message not too
long ago around
Hisham you always have tech recruiters
on when you're gonna have people that
are in the sort of construction real
estate market because it's however
biggest mark one of the earth markets in
their UK how have you not had them run
on so I'm excited to unpack your journey
I mean you've worked a one-room agency
for just one yes one four five and bit
years and just to sort of frame up
before we dive into sort of your story
have you so you as it been the typical
route of join it as a trainee or consult
and then sort of climb the ranks yeah
totally like that joined on on a grad
scheme it was pretty long grass commit
as 12 weeks okay it was good you
basically spent two weeks in each of our
desks and at the end of it you know five
or six desks at the end of it you you
pick the one you gravitate towards most
and they kind of pick you two and it
ends up working quite well because you
don't want to have you know a round peg
in a square hole yeah that's very
interesting we don't quite do it like
that anymore just cuz three months is a
long time before you start billing me
which is fair enough
but it worked well for me because I
genuinely couldn't decide between
different areas and I'll be honest I
knew nothing about real estate yeah so
it gave me a good bit of insight so how
as I was saying before were always like
to start how did you end up on a grad
scheme as a relief and I'm sure you
didn't know it plans went to uni right
yeah so you know I did philosophy
Wow yeah and unless you you live in
ancient Greece it doesn't leave any
doesn't lead to any obvious career so I
finished my degree and I finished it
early I finished it
my third year in March because it was
all coursework and I just banged up the
coursework all at once so I had
like three months of spare time before
graduating where did you go you knew
Brooks
okay yeah and I just had a good few
months they able to look for a job
mm-hmm and I made it my full-time job
looking for a job yes seriously I always
help something it's like I think all the
finger focusing on so I was back in
Eastbourne with my family house and I
was just applying for every job Under
the Sun like in the same half-hour I'd
applied to be a web designer and then a
lawyer like I was applying but
everything I was I was on like page 18
of indeed.com and I had like 11
different types of covering letters I
was using I'd made it a full-time job I
couldn't stand the thought of graduating
and then having like nothing that would
be alike unthinkable so I was applying
for everything and when you apply for
everything you come across recruiting a
lot mmm there's just a lot of jobs in
recruitment and I was trying to find a
job in Eastbourne to begin with because
I like the idea and I'm opportunity to
know honestly nothing like you vers
elicitor or there's light there's not
much like I was applying for jobs at a
spawn council oh my god it was like so
boring I thought it was amazing it was
like you're gonna pay you twelve K and
you're gonna like do our minutes at the
meeting I was like I was looking that
thing and that it would be quality
honestly I just didn't know any
different I'd applied to be like a web
designer like I said before knowing
nothing about it obviously not getting
the job and then I broadened it to
Brighton yeah could you offer me spawn
right yeah and bright and Ryan opens up
a lot yeah it's like Eastbourne on
steroids yeah I mean and there was a lot
more going on in price and and I got
some interviews and I started
interviewing in recruitment firms not
getting the jobs yeah Club wasn't
interviewing work very well yeah I
wasn't good at the questions and some of
the questions are pretty stupid did you
interview at cobalt and Brian no no no
no I said I did I got into it when I was
applying for equipment jobs I applied
yeah yeah and you got an interview yeah
I had a phone interview I'll come over
the chat slowly yeah yeah he actually
helped me a lot
yeah because when I was interviewing and
it was a phone interview and he was like
I do really like your energy mate but
you're just speaking way too quickly and
like are you that really helped me
because I was like right I need to just
relax I still struggle with that that's
good advice isn't it yeah
so so you ended up interviewing a number
of Brian recruitment
yeah and London and London because I
started to get it so I gained like May I
need to get a job next month
yeah because my parents are really
supportive but they weren't just gonna
start bankrolling me to live in their
house I need to get a job next month I
wouldn't want that person no no no no no
it's good it's good
so I start I apply for Co bottom
bryerson and they interview me in the
London office the rationale being that I
do like a grad scheme there and then I
might relocate to Brighton but then as I
started at COBOL and I think it was me
and them I think Chris RMD got me in the
room like 8-week cinemas like Tommy
don't really want to go to Brighton
really because bright at that time was
much more construction led and I'm
actually more real estate like
investment and it was like an officer
for that office is now disbanded yeah
one really good guy in Brighton and he
comes up and he has infrastructure but
it wasn't like a huge opportunity there
and I had already in like a few weeks
fall in love with London so it was a bit
like you know what I'm probably gonna
stay here now well did you pick Kober
did you have other opportunities
although the ones that the blunt answer
is they were the only ones that offered
me really at a time knowing nothing I'm
really glad lead in the hindsight but
I'd be lying if I was like there was
something yeah yeah I didn't get any
other jobs they gate they did the best
interview though I had other interviews
and it was I wasn't very good but also
like they asked me questions like if you
only had 10 pounds what would you invest
in and I was like eh you don't need to
know that at all be if you only have 10
pounds you need urgent help you
shouldn't be investing that money you're
gonna be disappearing homeless need to
like get help that little bit of money
like buy a lot of canned food and I'd
have to work my way through this absurd
answer about what I do run in a tunnel
and I just don't think that way and I
came up with this horrible answer one of
the interviews about how I buy like
tonnes of ice cream put it in cool boxes
go to the beach and sell ice cream on
site to or that were really hot and
thirsty which made no Sara's which made
no sense because ice cream even even
cheap ice creams like what like one
penny I don't know how much these cool
boxes are going to cost there's gonna
have to be people helping me so I'm
operating at a loss already you know it
wasn't it wasn't kind of worth doing any
of those horrible assessment centres no
well here's my point
cobalt had one of those horrible
assessments and really but I actively
b'fer that
because I'd rather you get me in a room
and we do a bunch of exercises that
actually designed around the job then
you get me in the room and ask me a
bunch of like googled entrepreneurial
questions that mean nothing about what I
do have a tenor offensive equipment co
but it was a full day of interviews and
you could not hide if you were bad if
you weren't made for it
they are gonna find everything though
and we had to do like these these role
plays that at the time just felt really
quite grueling but then the if and I
think it was 12 of us they were gonna
hire four from 12 so I mean we were in
this boardroom and like Tim the founder
is talking to us it was really
impressive that we had an amazing office
in Soho Square hours I was kind of sold
right they were the only people that
offered me but I was kind of sold I
really liked it
and it was like role plays in the
morning then we do like a written exam
in like the in like 11:00 o'clock like
we're going to write adverse they were
mark yeah bad Emily in the afternoon
there be a role play where Chris or MD
was sit as know him and be like look
guys what's the worst job you ever had
and I used to work at the ground hotel
in Eastbourne
okay and he was quite cruel he was like
okay Tom show me that job knowing I
hated it I'll have to find a way to sell
it and I still think that's the best
thing I've ever done and anything to
sell about job to Chris thing I've ever
I don't think I've ever engineered an
arts I bet or not I somehow managed to
make it sound like not only was that job
good and good for me to get into
recruitment but that it was like an on
brainer like if you're not working at
this hotel and you want to go into
recruitment you need to go to the hotel
phone is no brain and I managed to do it
and then they offered me and and
literally ever since then I've just not
even thought about it like I've
literally you say five years and it's
mental because that's a long time mate
particularly in recruitment yeah yeah
yeah one in recruitment and also at one
firm yeah that's really interesting I
think we spoke about this the the live
event I did a bit of a circle
competition a young an event it was like
what do people think the sort of average
tenure is for a recruitment concern and
business I
and it was okay I always forget it was
it was it was like 14 or 16 months
something like that
serious that wasn't like that isn't sort
of 14 and 16 months in the industry that
was like in one company firm 8 cents
rather than for 60 months in equipment
to go by me so same inertia pit you move
in yeah so you're like moving sideways
diagonally yeah yeah however members so
to be in one will cream in business for
five plus years like that so that's a
that's a really great thing yeah in a
nutshell right so yeah so one really
keen to do mate is is really sort of
break down the law sort of five or so
years so let's start with the first 12
months always lots of speeds people a
bit about this so obviously a 90 90 of
those days was the sort of grad scheme
so yeah he was indifferent he was
working in different markets and
different things so and how were they
sort of first 12 months overall they
were really good really yeah yeah they
were really good
in September I joined my current team
full-time is called the general practice
team we just do surveyors and investment
and asset managers basic those at buy
and sell buildings and once I started on
that team had just started really
clicking really yeah it was a good it
was a good start I'd be lying if I told
you it was like this grind for a year I
had a good bit of success at the start
because I think I came into a pretty
good market in 2014
mm-hmm a lot of the messaging at the
time was its 2014 its kind of post
credit crunch yeah I wrote a bit of a
bounce hmm and for people who spend the
money spending money and I'll be real
with you I was in the team that had
always had the most success historically
like when COBOL formed it was a team it
formed from mmm so I had a lot on my
side and you had a legacy crying yeah a
lot of warm clients I had to BD a lot
for sure but I'd be lying if I told you
there's like this completely ice-cold
desk I had great managers and I had a
lot of support and it just felt like the
market was on my side I wasn't like
fighting as the current no I empathize
but without start hidden like you know
2017 was a tough year the latter portion
of last year was tough there's good
things about starting when it's tough
like habits you learn I think when you
when you have to learn fast and quick
for me it clicked quite quickly really I
did good 12 months yeah would you when
you say klitz what you mean just it
sense right when I came to COBOL I was
just I was fortunate I'd worked like odd
jobs so I worked in Tesco John my gap
year and I was contracted for twelve
hours but I worked much more and I were
sort of at the Grand Hotel for like two
summers for three months during unions
for six months total and I knew the
value of doing a good shift and that's
really important to do I wasn't sure if
I would be good at those jobs I didn't
and you don't know do you and like I
wasn't actually sure with it I would be
good because others I come from this
light English literature philosophy type
University you just don't think so
you're gonna be settled yeah I mean it
yeah that's what I mean it's you don't
really you don't strike me as a salesy
person not at all and I'm and I'll be
honest like I'm not I am money motivated
but I'm not gonna person that just gonna
go out and buy a Rolex at all and I just
I wasn't the character you'd think and
actually Tim our founder said when he
into me was like I was wobbling Tom to
be honest because I wasn't sure about
you really and I totally get it I don't
hold it against you because you wouldn't
meet me and be like that's a absolute
wolf of Wall Street that's the opposite
of what I am I don't think that's not
that's what sort of Mei Mei nice a good
recruit these days though that's that
would mean that you'd be great a
recruitment these days you know I mean
and as cheesy as it is I'm actually not
trying to make some weird sale I
actually like to look at a building when
I walk into work and be like I put sixty
percent of that company there they came
to me in 2015 when they were just
starting and now everyone that isn't a
part that I like that that's what I like
and obviously I won't complain about the
money side but I really like the
emotional side of it mmm genuinely in
more sense just knowing that you you
you've you've got a difficult mandate it
seems impossible or tricky and you've
kind of taught you pros as we're talking
the client round a bit about what's
possible mmm positioning of our to a
candidate per take leave us like a Nisha
area and just making the to marrying the
two and out that person's been there
three years I like that they've been art
isn't it yeah I think it's I think it's
understated I think in particularly an
area where you have to know a bit of
knowledge around it to sell properly and
explain you know I think honestly I
think it it's it's it's financially
rewarding but if you do it right it's
quite rewarding emotion yeah that's the
part I like I really like that yeah how
was gonna say so any any sort of big
challenges in the
Shir then the country lunges um anything
that you struggled with but did you
start bidding quite quickly then yeah I
did
really I did it away a poem poem yeah
I'm I've had slower year since but like
the first year we did I did to 12
[ __ ] now yeah I did to top but that
doesn't include that that's just that
son that's January 25th that's January
2015 to end of year yeah yeah that's
decent
yeah and I did 40 and Q in from
September to the end of 2014
really yeah so I had a good start these
are still I'd be honest my best still
that's done with that really yeah that's
menses you're your first year it's in
recruitment yeah was your best year it
was still my best year hope if I go down
was my best year ever
in 25th in 2016 I did 220 yeah and then
20k fan out two months off of the year
ended so I went down I think it was
still on the figures so I don't know if
you know whatever that means but yeah so
maybe from an admin point of view I
still did it but a federal I had to
backfill it so it would that would have
been 200 odd yeah so that's been your
best year it's been my best that's crazy
I mean yeah so it's not like it was
clicking and I never do you think that's
sort of that Connaught that's always it
also has its negatives right because and
then it's like from year one you've had
this that you have an expectation on
your shoulder the rest light and when
200 okay Plus Billa yeah because
honestly in today's market the
conversations I've had I put a post out
not that too long ago around like what
what are what's like water steam as a
good biller and a lot of people came
back to that and was like if you're a
few billion 200 k plus in today's market
like that's a great place to be yeah if
your billion if you were spinning around
circle hundred fifty 180 light as
someone that's employing you like you've
got a great person there that's that's
really bring a lot of value to the
business but if you're breaking that
200k mark Dean was a good better so to
do that in your first year then the
expectation and precious high yeah yeah
precious high like honestly and
rightfully so because like I said I
wasn't a good team no there's not like
they were asking too much I was I should
I should have been doing that my boss
was doing more was you free 60
yeah oh yeah from day one day one yeah
hundred percent yeah okay 360 that's
crazy um the grad scheme is great we
don't do anymore but that that
three-month of learning all the team's
learning how light debt and equity works
all of that stuff it helps makes you
makes you feel credible how important
yeah so how did you go about I think
that that's definitely a challenge for
people even more experience like how
have you how have you gotten about like
really understanding your market like
how have you gone about doing that
because I can imagine in your world
that's I mean like any market but how
important is that to so important really
so important you don't get me wrong you
can overthink it you can over prepare
calls and ya learn you can write in to
me notes but if you know your stuff and
it comes through organically not just
the knowledge but who's in the market so
you can name drop contacts and people
you've placed there hearing there it's
the difference maker because one thing I
will say I'm in a good team right it's a
very saturated environment we've got a
lot of competition and there's a new
competitor every day okay and it's hard
to stand out unless you're really good
because everyone knows it's a good
market when it's a good market it's not
a secret so people are going to try and
get into that oh yeah so it's really
good when I got the job at Cobra I got
it I knew I had it like first of June
hmm started 23rd of June and it's a bit
weird I know but I actually spent those
three weeks learning about real estate
in a weird that more people should do
that yeah I'm glad said that so I came
into work I knew nothing about really
someone interviewed and to the point
where they were like do you know
anything I'm not there like guys I have
really direct approach to interviews I'd
be completely honest yeah that's why I
wasn't getting jobs because I'd be like
I don't that wants to have a tenor
you know animation and and and I don't
know anything about property and I don't
really know why I'm here I'm here
because I was on page 13 am indeed calm
applied for the other pages now yeah so
I have a real straightforward approach
so I just tell her how it is and but
when I actually got the job and I knew I
was like I've just got to make this work
now I'm even gonna make it work yeah
like coffee you really focused and just
put yeah yeah I really I'm gonna make
this my mission to make this work really
yeah so what and just quickly just ran
that off I think where it's a where did
you start like where did you start to
know more about the market he's gonna
recruit for is it just a simple Google
job start learning from the job titles
what they do
just get some real core knowledge yeah
really cool how how has that helped
how is it actually helped you and why
should people do that if they haven't or
don't do that yeah well in a really
basic sense you just get the breadth of
what industry are in and so I think I
think it helps you contextualize what
you're doing I know that if I'm
recruiting for an asset manager I just I
knew coming in to Cobo not as much I do
now but I kind of knew where they fit in
the pyramid of roles to ever have that
role on I know whether I'm being sincere
in Himes positioning it or not yeah and
there's nothing worse than someone who
has a blatantly bad role no offense I
mean there are bad rolls out there
aren't there and I can hear it ok over
here them trying to make out as like
this brilliant role much better to say
let's be honest is the stepping-stone
role I'll be real with you it's a
stepping-stone role but I reckon and I
believe that it can get you here if you
stick it out for two years and doing the
job then make out that this role is
gonna be like the be-all and end-all
that's my works hmm and I just like to
hear people be honest and knowing our
industry coming into it let me feel like
I was confident and honest because
actual confidence comes a lot later yeah
I can fake it to your maker type thing
yeah so you got a talk like you know
what you're saying a bit sooner than you
will know yeah that's really nice yeah
you've got to just take some chances and
I say to people a lot like you're trying
to be too perfect mmm we're trying to
like you're making all these notes about
this client but if you just give them a
call tell them how it is and be honest
and show a bit of knowledge then that
counts for more I'll feel like a more
human interaction and I even go further
I say why don't you give yourself
permission to make a bad call your first
call be bad but just get on the phone
get a bit of a mentor and then it will
come but you've been too long like tryna
get also I'm not advocating for people
to spend weeks on air I spent three
weeks then I learned in the job a lot
yeah by cooling that's the best way of
learning yeah but I didn't like coming
in totally blind
so I spent energy I think also it's come
up quite a lot but to have the sort of
humility and to communicate the humility
to the people that you were speaking to
to sailor can you just explain that bit
again because I don't quite unlike that
right and that's that's come on cause I
love that and actually I'm lucky because
recruitment and real estate where we
recruit into it is a very people
industry mmm people frankly love to talk
about themselves exactly so I actually
say to people a lot
I just thought you just said yes tell
them where your knowledge ends and
begins and just let them talk about
their lives most people love it the best
part is the people that love doing it
are the ones that are most senior mmm
wake up yeah marked for twenty years
because they could they pretty work come
home the pretty with their kids anyway
and it's like they can just have a good
chat with you and you learn from them
and the biggest shock was that people
just actually like to speak to you you
know some people don't know us
definitely not everyone but some people
do and that's when you actually learn as
much as you might go on your computer
and read the theory that's been going on
so dunno sort of figures early on yeah
was you around big billows like was your
and many people that were doing more
than that yeah yeah really the most
important part is my boss was doing more
than that really and I still think if
you to be a really good boss and it's
hard I get me wrong you got to leave
from the front
yeah because you if I'm gonna listen to
you and trust you you need frankly you
need to be a big building because
otherwise it's a tricky scenario and I
feel that bird and a lot now that I
manage I need to be up there with the
the I need to be in the top five I need
to be building well because they're
gonna trust you and I learn faster from
you if you have that quality so he was
that credibility doesn't that when you
ask me advice and I definitely got into
a team with that culture where my boss
build really well in her boss the head
of the team was building outstandingly
well and it just felt that wasn't sort
of figures with a billion so I think so
let so that the the lady who managed me
like 250 if not more and but I remember
actually when I joined her team in
September her chief my q4 was forty her
keep her q4 was a hundred Wow amazing I
doing 100 headquarters just incredible
and then our that the head of the team
he I think he was literally like a 350
400 K Bello how much of an impact do you
think that had because I I think what
this has come up a lot and I think like
again you may may not be aware this
because you've been in the same yeah
business but I think thinking about how
much of an impact do you think it had
that being around those people who've
seen those sort of numbers that made it
realistic and achievable from from the
get it's absolutely huge
yeah because to 12 it didn't feel
unachievable whatever in that year
no one was like take it easy you're six
months hearing it felt actually kind of
felt like you need you know make hay
while the Sun shines
I got told a lot like this isn't normal
we're in a good market right now and you
really ought to be at that level and I
was around people so I think you know I
was head the head of the team then my
boss then me we would have been like the
for a couple years would have been the
top three villas in that team at least
in the company there were some other
people but generally speaking at Cobalt
if you're doing kind of 200 you're doing
really well
that's roughly yeah I think it was just
interesting that there were a lot of
people listening at them there may not
be anyone in their office doing - um
okay like yeah and this income of cada
Tong's where if you're not around people
doing those sort of figures then that's
just and you're like that constantly for
the last four years you bill 150 hundred
names like that you want okay it's just
that's can't there but when you were
then but you yeah but you've been
straight in there and you've been around
people there's the standards do you not
I mean yeah I think that that's that
must have definitely momen or realized a
bit it's like now is why would that not
be realistic when there's people around
me oh yeah more yeah I mean yeah it was
it was great honestly okay so when so
year two was you very much obviously
still bidding at that point right when
in year two I start managing really yeah
so did you want to have money no what
happened is the head of the team the
head of Yadav he left okay he left like
late summer early winter which created a
small vacuum and the team yeah where
mine boss stepped up to be the head of
and then suddenly and she was taking
over some stuff somebody had a few
people that won't be managed and I
picked up one of those to manage just
one person yeah in September maybe okay
and ever since I've been managing it
very quickly I had a second person a
third and a fourth so how many messaging
four people so I've been managing four
people about three years okay yeah it's
a pretty much yeah nearly the whole time
pretty yeah as you start after that
first year so that first year was the
first time it was I was like a solo
self-motivate yella the other times I've
been trying to to retain that and lead
from the front while also trying to
manage and pass on things when I
and create a desk your natural
self-contained desk so my internal
rationale that's not an excuse to was
like I want us to think of it in
hindsight quite easy if you're only
thinking about yourself every day I know
for sure to come in and do that what's
more challenging is getting to those
numbers or in that territory but also
being selfless and passing on roles not
totally selfish could you shoot should
still be financially better view to do
that but frankly isn't to begin with you
are making a small cut and just having
just doing that and and you know I
haven't I haven't build to 12 cents like
I said to 200 last year and the year
after that 2017 was a really tough year
that's what at my lowest really that's
when I first moved to like managing for
people ah that was so that was really
challenging really that's my main bit of
advice not really advice but something
to just tell people about is that when
you manage one or two in recruitment I
think you can still retain a good daily
patter with your own work when it's for
it's genuinely two jobs like you're
working two jobs hmm and everyone I've
seen you this company do that has has me
included you take a bit of a hit in
Billings how do you deal with that it
was hard not well I mean I didn't deal
with it well when you say well what do
you mean it was just 2017 was really
tough it was it was just like adapting
to the intensity of targets are still
there or don't you have what a nice but
it's like you've got to be brutally
honest with yourself for me it was about
looking at things and being like when a
deal falls out or something you know
it's about being brutally honest with
yourself mm-hmm it's like how much of
that was my fault some things can't be
controlled if someone gets counted 25k
because that business can't lose them
and I get a counteroffer
what I found is if you're real with
yourself most of the time it is
something in there is your phone so it
wouldn't look in the mirror how could
I've done that that yeah did I do
everything I possibly could often you've
got if you're honest you could have done
something better and that weirdly is a
good thing yeah because you can actually
work on that it's hard when you're like
I can't think of it this called counter
20k I would also stay if suddenly my
study went from 80 to 100 and 5 yeah but
it's better so ideal
that by taking a bit of time honestly
just just to not think and then I really
think and unlike I've been a bit brutal
I'm like what could I have done
differently and I want there to be
something I could have done I mean I'm
like right I'm not doing that again
hmm and then I generally improve right
did you think about quittin uh I don't
think so not in 2017 no I I don't think
no matter how bad it got I just really
felt like I wanted to make it work like
I was really I remember like and I
turned it round so I think I think
literally in August 2017 I was on maybe
90 K yeah which is so much lower than
I've ever been on before and that year I
still did like 171 yeah so I had a huge
yeah how do you I don't know how do you
think you've got for that cuz a lot of
so a lot a lot of people message me yeah
let's just think about some of the
things maybe it's a what that's one of
the things so yeah so to give you
context a lot people mess to me and it's
hisham really struggling this or I'd
love you to speak to people about how
they push through that period bubble and
this is clearly a tough period that you
had some I'm keen to stay on it so so
something that you became more and more
comfortable with was when things started
to not go your way right Tom what could
have done better self a flash and
self-reflection yes that's something
definite did but when you when you was
in you said August so using all yeah all
good 90k I care right so if I don't pick
this up like what are some of the things
that you think you started to do or you
made part of your daily patterns or
whatever the enable you to shift it but
it's having a little bit mental as I
actually did this thing where I
pretended like I was in a documentary
and I was a camera crew following me and
I was it was like can this guy save his
year that was a documentary really and I
was like what would I do if I was like
part of a TV show where I had to make it
work and I was being screwed and I was
being scrutinized visualize this yeah
like what would you do like you see this
things over time like like these these
documentaries where someone's in like a
really adverse situation and you
followed them as a they turn it around I
was like if I put myself in that context
imagine if I was being scrutinized by
like dozens of people yeah watching my
every word and it was like watch my
every action listened to every word and
it was like here's the journey to turn
it around
and I actually pretended I wasn't like
that kind of thing yeah and it forced me
to be like is what I'm currently doing
if I'm doing what I'm doing now would I
actually be proud of it if I like a crew
following me around like I might
actually am I actually right now just
wasting time and energy on role I know I
can't fill and I just started holding
myself to this standard wow there's like
I'm gonna raise my game like in in this
really mental way but where did that
come from I heard about I heard it I
think it was on the Joe Rogan podcast
either really like he made this comment
about he was talking to this fitness guy
about how he did it and he was just like
yeah I just I I just put myself in a
scenario where it was like everything I
do has to be doing everything I do is
towards one goal and if it isn't how
would I feel if I was actually in a
scenario where I'm being scrutinized for
it it's quite easy to get way of things
in recruitment even if you even if
you're an invite where you're hard
pinned on stats you can really
comfortably if you don't want to be
successful you can you can comfortably
just take shortcuts and I was not
interested how can I make it so I turn
this around and the final thing I did
was I might sound a bit weird but I
actually woke up and realized there's a
lot more in the world than recruitment
and I found ways to escape because
certainly in that first year 2015-2016 I
was really obsessed really yeah really I
was a missing tube stop thinking about
coming into what I think life kills
women come in yeah I was really it was
very young new to London there wasn't a
lot going on my life yeah and more
what's happened since now I just think
there's a lot of value in switching off
females the weekend yeah and just
forgetting about it and just watching
the football or something gave you a bit
more clarity when you are here yes so
then when you are in it might feel like
you're skipping on what but when you are
in you you have a totally fresh
perspective and now suddenly something
that was eluding you on the Friday
because you've actually switched off you
come in and it's like no I kind of get
what to do now that break so when you
when you had that sort of yeah that sort
of mindset switch on raising your game
standards what were some of the things
that you started implementing or some of
the things that you started to realize
we like well I could definitely that
better or
you've made some sort of tweaks or
changes that had a good path I had this
problem in 2017 where I had like three
hundred and nineteen years my first
interviews which was really high but I
was just working roles where that they
would interview and then it wouldn't
really go anywhere yeah I was working
with lots of these like investment
practices that were quite small and
boutique here and they'd have like
impossible standards they'd meet
everyone under the Sun and then no one
be good enough mmm a bit of info on that
but he was getting an interview yeah so
it was weird one and and and I think
rightly so but the way we treat things
here as we look at interview it's hard
yes as I met Rick we look at interviews
and so on the face of it that look like
I'm doing wrong smashing it I remember I
had like the most most interviews in the
company 319 interviews and anything it
was that much it was a lot I was over
300 I'll have to see I think it was a
know a typical metric that led that men
that gave you the best possible chance
of and in the figures you did yeah you
written what you realized I realized it
was not worthless but I realized that it
was harming my success wasn't as
valuable yeah I thought no because I was
getting interviews in the wrong places I
know that sounds really weird but and I
started being brutal with my time and I
started and a few things happen at once
the people I was managing started
becoming more self-sufficient which was
good okay so I put nine months into
trying to make them really good and it
was starting to really work one of the
ladies I managed was the highest
building mom start in 2017 oh wow the
other guy managed who I took over when
that chap left I mention at the start
the first person I managed in September
2015 he did 190 that year all right so
the people so it's starting to work I
had like a slow yeah as I was training
and giving quieter doing that and then
when it clicked and they start billing
it almost helped and at the same time I
became more realistic with a little time
I had to do my own billing I was like I
can keep getting into these places where
you have to be perfect to get the job or
I can work positions which on the face
of it seemed different and slightly you
know I don't know like you don't wanna
say worse but sometimes positions that
seem less attractive and your stepping
stone rolls but actually they're ready
to happen an urgent and that was the
main mentality switch really yeah
honestly and
and then and that was enough to there's
a bit of both and then then I kind of
switched it around it's really
interesting so and then anything around
a few things that switches around you
really valuing your time I think that's
such a really interesting insight
because I think a lot of people but
should you do the majority of stuff
continuing yeah yeah so that's the thing
right so it's like again there's so many
recruiters listening right now that the
majority the work they do they're not
getting paid for right so like it was
that anything else that you become
really straight of your time on I mean
was it that I don't know you had really
strict and things in your diary where
like you had to do certain things at
certain times or you recognized that
clients had to sort of hit a certain
thing for you to be like yeah this is a
job I'm going to work I don't know then
if it was anything else on that not
really because I I've always approached
it like that even when I wasn't
performing top tier I've always been
like can I you valued your time yeah I
was I value my time but also I'm a big
believe I'm a big hater of like 8:00
a.m. 8:00 p.m. recruitment firms yeah I
just think when you have a time schedule
like that I think I work better in like
a smaller window when I have an urgency
to it and I'm like I need to get this
done that's when I produce some of the
best things I do I think if you have
like an endless amount of time to sit
there patter around and do like the odd
call because the days 12 hours long that
just harms of the culture so I always
had an approach where I wouldn't stay at
work for no reason but I'd force myself
to have a really productive eight hours
or seven hours right so I would never
leave the office about having a short
this scent whatever I got on that day I
where advertised all the basics I'll
make sure I mean I would hate going home
knowing I've half-ass there really and
that's because at that time I spent
before recruitment just working what I
would consider really hard jobs yes it's
actually harder that as hard as giving
is harder being a waiter on being
screamed at by chefs cleanup by
customers it's it's half 11:00 at night
you'll feel almost bleeding you've been
there nine hours you're hungover that's
harder learning the value of a hard
shift really puts into perspective I was
such a bad waiter as a way of a lot of
free chefs anyway yeah
in the harbor could and the Picasso yeah
that's the place with the tinted window
yeah a window so I did like free shifts
free shifts their free shifts there and
I'll just absolutely crumbled a lot
honestly yes so yeah one of the shifts
are dropping like two pizzas yeah and I
was only carrying two pizzas life was
bad yeah so I totally get that
okay cool so just just on that point and
then I'd love to sort of dive into your
management experience and I think a lot
do get value out of that so yeah with
that with that in mind what how do you
typically structure your day was that
typically like you're quite rigid with
that or no really no you don't have sort
of set blocked out no no times my
rationale and that's the best thing
about recruitment is every single day is
really different every day is so
different so if I have a set plan for
every day I'm I'm not going to be
competitive no I mean so I come in and
one thing I always do it looks like I'm
a child but I always do it is I do a
morning list okay are things that just
have to be done that morning yeah
they're not the lunch I make a lunch
list things that have to be done and if
it's a late one I do like it and even
English I think something have to be
done before I go I'm gonna make sure you
do make but what it is it's different
every single day yeah I'm not gonna
leave work without without doing the key
things but if something happens
overnight I come in and I see it and
suddenly that's the priority yeah
little things like I'll always if
there's interview requests I'm gonna try
and get those in sooner rather than
later crass night on those then someone
was hot you know someone's available a
half one they no longer are and that's
only because I was lazy and way to 20
minutes to book it I can't stand that
yeah yeah I would hate myself I never do
that yeah so those things I'm doing
right away other things lots of
flexibility and I've always operated on
the metric of I do what makes money
first mainly even though I'm not a
cold-hearted money motivator person I
think a good way of structuring your day
is being a bit commercial about is like
will that make me money or is that just
a nice thing to do it's calling back
that person who I can't realistically
helped and I've told them this hmm
and the cord again anyway the best thing
for me to do it might be the nicest
thing but actually if I get this
shortlist I'll that's going to help me
yeah no I think that's a great mindset
to have isn't it when you're approaching
talents and what you should be spending
on
and stuff and when I was on my grad
scheme it was I spent two weeks on this
team that was super volume driven okay
which is very different to me but I
bought like three rolls a month right
really well met like six yeah and you
try and fill half of them and I'm couple
more get put into next month and it's
all good
this team was like eleven a week yeah
and that two weeks taught me everything
it taught me so much it taught me I
bring that ethos to this desk I'm
working this lower desk but with the
urge of Zeeland and a lease of it as if
I've got all and it just forces you to
get things done and it just makes you
really realistic with your time and when
you start managing it's that times 10
because suddenly you've got someone you
need to advise or want to have a quick
moment in the meeting room one-on-one
just talk through some strategies or
they they have a complaint until they
have a question on salary or something
well you have like it like I do this
week for appraisals from one week all
right they're gonna be an hour each and
I've got to marry that with trying to
still hit punchy individual targets so
that that really let's talk about
management then so so do so just to be
clear then so you ended up taking on
under your wing one person that quickly
turns to ya people and then it's been
four people for like three years
yeah so let's start with what have been
the biggest challenges a new in you
managing these people would you say
yeah well the the Box tandem one at the
start was was keeping up what was a was
a big building expectation for my first
year going into my second year okay was
that expectation himself or expectation
with the people above you thanking
myself really I have never been made to
feel bad on the buildings
I really literally never even once yeah
so that's more of your own standards
yeah my own standards I think I've
always build at a level where I'm always
around 200 right so I think it's always
been satisfactory and I've always had
people around me that are doing that but
it was hard I think I think honestly
we're going to start managing you need
to be in a good position building as
wise before you do it really cuz I think
there might be a bit of a drop mmm I
think I think particularly over managing
multiples you might suffer a quick drop
in Billings it's not a longer one and if
you if that starting point is 200 to 170
it's better than 150 to 130 yeah
so that was a big one so we so your
advice would be if you're in the process
of managing more people have a real
little heart in itself and like how how
good is my desk right now I've got some
good relationships that are gonna yeah
definitely fruitful would frankly make
sure your your your roughly speaking at
200 K s maybe 180 190 level Bella
because you need to be at a level where
if you have a bit of a drop which I can
say is natural you're still able to be
in a decent position and make money for
yourself also because when you have
someone join your team in a perfect
world you give them a few easy warm
rolls to get their confidence up mmm
while they graft new clients you have a
bit because you're warm enough to give
them a few things
yeah it's that combination so you have
to do you have to do a service list of
people that come and join you yeah and
also look at your own Billings yeah yeah
so that and that's tricky so that was a
hard part of management mmm that was one
of the challenges I've always been lucky
with managing I think good hard-working
people so I've never had to deal with
like really difficult situation like
someone I just think what you're doing
it never had that chat I think we
recruit fairly well was there anything
so it's coming you you would just send
there where you might be pulled aside or
whatever they have you had that's come
up a few times where a couple of people
realized that they were getting pulled
aside for the finish that they protocol
have worked out themselves so came up a
bit of a system where you was like look
guys if you if you need to speak to me
you can but let's unless it's like
urgent talk to me in this sort of when
the other night have you did you have
you come up with anything or so I don't
like the window idea okay I know people
do that yeah my rationale is like I hate
the idea of someone sitting there
simmering on something and not doing
waiting because there wasn't any and
yeah I hate that no just asked have you
know did you find that a challenge
though that you yeah oh yeah yeah it's
challenging but it worked because these
people ended up being big billers yeah
so when I look back at 2017
I just think of it as a hard year but
one that eventually I'd turn round
somehow because of the camera crews yeah
and then and also the two people ended
up doing quite well so I was a harder so
why do you think they did well I think I
think it was a they were joining a
pretty successful culture
I think they had the benefit of someone
who had a couple years under the belt
like it like I did and was I've really
made sure they knew the market like I
prioritized teach them about the market
we'd have some one-on-ones I was like
this is how it works they had some good
clients to crack home with they weren't
having to grind pass on that he was
crying fast a couple of things like for
for one of the chaps I I took on in that
in that October of 2015 and passed on
some roles to him that he filled or some
of the consultants who use and stuff and
it just gets your confidence up a bit
more yeah and they were really good like
not talking over them that they would
they were great so they they wanted it
too and that really helps so they were
there were people that would listen
they'd follow the structure I had in
mind they'd bring their own ideas to the
party
I love when you're managing someone and
they actually surprised you mmm like
they actually are like they give you a
perspective like Michael I wouldn't
think of that candidate like that's a
good field here they were those kind of
people so I was lucky that I had good
people like that but yeah basically how
you will market like because I think as
I said at the beginning like from your
experience and obviously you haven't
been in any other markets but like how
it has it been a really fruitful market
there's sort of real estate and
construction yeah I think it's been it's
been a weird one it has been on the
whole but you really feel it in this
market when there's a blip yeah because
I think it's one of those things if
you're gonna buy property and it's 400
million pounds yeah and you're unsure
nine times out of 10 you might prolong
that no we're a bit late was it's such a
risk a building a tentative building
where any of the tenants who go into
administration and that's the suffering
point in the recession or the building
could tank and value or you're gonna
development you're halfway through a
development that has to finish and the
markets tanked so now the the price you
had in mind isn't gonna work there's so
much risk attack one of the riskier
sectors and we really feel it because
like you're not gonna grow your team in
an environment where you're sitting on
your hands waiting to do a deal how can
you can't really objection and Allah
like I know what you do is you're just
you really really this is about 2017
again which was a huge year for me it's
about shifting your focus from roles
where they've historically been really
prestigious European and
rollers people that kind of buying
buildings and you shift it towards
things like like insolvency for instance
is when a building goes into
administration there are certain
surveyors that specialize in turning
that around so they really those roles
thrive in Hana yeah it's suddenly you
need service oh you're still recruiting
you want to look at your market and be
like is there at where the opportunity
here and Allison oft often there is and
so I pivot and you and what was an
awesome role two months ago might not be
and as soon he comes the realization the
better mmm I came to that realization in
later than I would have hope but enough
time to turn things around and yeah
that's really interesting I think again
I think that's the sort of mindset piece
isn't it's like you could you could have
sat there and gone brexit as Breck see
it's this is this and not taking any
accountability and you was willing there
to go right okay well we're what people
were getting the opportunities out of
this this environment and this market
what was deceptive is that they're happy
to interview yeah these these investment
that was happy to interview but unless
someone's putting honest so sure you
know they're gonna be like you know what
you might actually just hold back and
wait yeah
so I think we was speaking a bit about
it briefly before we started but what
I'd love to get your thoughts on because
we've sort of touched on it but
resilience yeah it's important in
recruitment isn't that yeah it's hard
how have you personally gone about
cultivating that because you're someone
that's had to cultivate that in your and
yeah aim as well as a manager so how
have you cultivated that in your in the
sort of yourself and your team yeah okay
well part part one of it is is when you
have a setback and you'll have lots is
being brutally honest with yourself you
know first and foremost about what
happens and why it happened and there
will be times when people when you talk
to people about people and you're trying
to place people with people people are
chaotic yeah so all it takes is for one
of the people in the equation to just
have a complete change of heart or for
their partner to and then they've told
them to change their mind and it can
fall apart no matter your best
intentions yeah but like I said to
earlier actually there are a lot of
times I may goes wrong you could have
improved you could have done something
you could have maybe met the mouth of a
second engine
because you've sensed a wobble in their
voice you could have asked him again
that point that yeah and the soon you
come to the realization that shook I can
tweak that the better that's that's one
thing right how did you how did you get
your team to take responsibility there
because that isn't a typical thing that
someone not not everyone's wouldn't be
accountable yeah but I was really lucky
because I I don't feel like I'm having
to force people to do this really yeah I
never feel like I'm telling look at me
like an alien like I've had really good
people that were like when I say this
they're like yeah because it's actually
it's a better feeling knowing you can
change it like the hardest thing I've
had to do as a manager was actually this
year already where we've had someone in
the Parisian market and there's but
Paris market isn't working mmm just
isn't working and it's you can't look at
and be like you you change this approach
you change this you can't really do that
because that we're external to it's
across the sea all of those things and
that's a harder conversation yeah easier
when you're like tweak this one out and
I reckon you'll get that they get people
like to hit I'd like to hear manager can
like spar with and be like I reckon you
should changes around I never had
someone be like no no I promise you
because they hopefully want help
yeah so the first thing is be willing
seeing take accountability as hard as it
is and know it's a good thing if there
are ways you can change it second thing
is to have more in your life than
recruitment yeah which is where I've got
it wrong early early on when I was like
23 it was my life have more in your life
than recruitment so that oh so that
after you've digested it you can escape
from it from there watch some football
go to the pub do whatever you want to do
like whatever you do how did you get
better that what I got a lot of things I
hope I start seeing yourself out there
in London and know people's stuff I just
grew up a little bit I've got I'm
married now like I just have such a life
outside of it like it gets easier little
things like I don't have my emails on my
phone really
which is probably really controversial
but I just don't because I just don't
think once again if I know but between 8
a.m. or half a team and half 5 p.m. I've
got this time to do this I work hard and
I mean low I just send a few miles from
home yeah
so I know me so I don't do that anymore
and I just and it helps you come in with
a much fresher perspective so I actually
think you know what I I probably don't
work less hard but I definitely there's
less intensity but which I think helps
so first and foremost be brutal with
yourself and if you could think of what
you did differently that's a good thing
if you can't don't be too hard on
yourself yeah like if someone's
literally been counter-offered forward
to their salary then just know that that
can happen despite all the assurances of
won't and then as soon as you've come to
that realization escape for a bit digest
it and enjoy your life realize that
there is more to this than recruitment
and then come in with a new perspective
ready to go again because you've got to
go again and it's going to happen again
also part 3 be realistic it's gonna
happen again
so no matter how bad it feels now it's
gonna happen again get ready for it even
how good it gets to the different
working it's like right like again it
comes to that don't be too high with the
highs and to lower the low like just
understand that it's gonna happen it's
gonna happen just make sure you enjoy
the highs
it's really weird of a creeper because
you often don't enjoy the high is
because you place someone and then if
you're a hungry person you're like on to
the next thing and it's quite an
unhealthy psychology because you
actually sit back like in that year like
when I did like 10 did I do build what I
actually look back I'd say I don't I
you don't really celebrate successes as
much because I had this quite weird
quite pessimistic approach right I
almost think that most things don't
happen yeah I have the approach of I
won't just deals done everyone seems
happy brilliant that's great but you
know what there's a very good chance it
just won't happen all again someone to
get ill or like how about the craziest
thing as a people like I've had someone
like get really injured in a skiing
accident over Christmas and they have
been able to start the company I plays
here and it's falling out that was 2016
yeah so I'm when I do a deal I know I'm
like I'm no no no I stayed grounded stay
grounded and most importantly get back
up options then like back up options
videos you've done or where even if you
have like loads of like we call them
projections that's like an industry-wide
tongue-like projections like all the
roles you have one in a month yeah and I
always say you need at least four
projections to me
money okay he got four rolls on one roll
the guy gets counter-offered loads of
money and it won't happen the other roll
the girl it delays and she's meeting the
next month now so it's out this month
and then in the other roll you got
unlucky and the other chap who isn't
from you is from one of her recruiter
picked your candidate to the post and
they've got the job but that's happened
a fourth time there's something truly
wrong with the prepare yeah so I always
look at my team and I'm not looking at a
team that is instantly billing but the
sooner they can get to a level where
there are four projections a month the
better because that to me is when you
can start making money and of course
some months it all clicks and you have a
50k month yeah like that but you need
four rolls on at interview otherwise
you're leaving it too much to charge
yeah you don't like that you don't get
unlucky you just have to have so much
going on and work so ferociously hard
that you deal with the obvious unlock
this out there just don't get complacent
take a place even you do the deal there
was one guy manage and it was like he'd
be like as a done deal is like really
all it takes is for someone to get you
you do that you do you put you're like
yeah that's that's a place you love it
you do get better at judging that but as
you said you also get better at you know
what this this could fall out
even though how come even how confident
you are about it yeah the sooner you get
there the better so actually that's when
that's when full fallouts can almost be
a healthy thing because you realize that
you should have actually still had a
couple of options you know what because
yeah and then you look at yourself and
balaiah
did I get a complaint in there did I
realize things to happen too much how
does business development fitting all
this then what you're talking about
there is if I'm if I'm always having for
potential offers for potential jobs
going my way each month that surely
that's got to require always doing the
business nuts yeah definitely what
should be in your experience that
because that's probably again a really
common topic and in terms of people
that's a big area that people struggle I
don't know what your team has been like
they've they've always had to get better
but that that can be rough area where a
lot of people struggle yeah business
very important it comes in so keeping in
touch with what the industries do mm-hmm
and I always think there's no point
business developing about a product and
I'm a crewman that product
so the spectrum people out I do it the
same way around every time I'm sure this
isn't that unique but I meet someone I
asked them what kind of companies they
like and they might say to my like X and
I'm really honest I say look like I also
have seen their movements they're really
impressive I know if people would have
gone there I'll be real with you I don't
actually yet have a contact but I can
easily mention I place some of their
competitors and if you're happy with
this I can have a chat see what they say
and then it goes from this cool where
you've called this random company
introducing yourself and who you work
for which no one cares about yeah no one
cares no one gives a damn about that and
maybe a couple of snippets of oh I see
you bought this warehouse in Luxembourg
which they also don't care about to
actually saying I've met this brilliant
asset manager they're fluent in France I
see you've just bought a few things in
France on ATK they'd really love to meet
you guys if you've any for a coffee and
then that's an actual call you have to
have the candid that's what I realized
is really Odion I don't think I was even
taught that that just came to me quite
naturally it's like you've got to have
an actual product for them to buy
otherwise it's just you yeah and and
that was a massive thing it's like just
just sell an actual product and then
they don't need to know you they just
want to see this candidate want to see
the candidate you send the CV it all
clicks together you send your terms and
that's how you get new business on yeah
so I'm assuming you you're telling your
guys to always be yeah obviously you get
better and on what a good candidate is
and what can a good candidate is to spec
out and stuff but that they've always
got to be working with candidates or
finding candidates that drum up business
it all starts began yeah i really
discourage anyone to just be like
drafting like these organisation names
have liked 11 in a row and just grew
back-to-back calls all through them
because you're not going to get anywhere
because why would they unless they
unless you get absolutely lucky and
you've managed to catch a client in the
middle of like genuine the urgent
recruitment and like yeah I do actually
recovery now which is unlikely yeah
you've got to kind of impress them with
a really good product mmm have you ever
it's been spoken about a lot but if you
ever sort of had success in speaking to
senior people about jobs and then
flipping those people into hiring
managers so if you're if you're
approaching Haron moni's with with sort
of senior jobs that could also be your
client have you ever done know it's mean
like it's too light so obviously I don't
know
what a typical job title is for your
nose but if you have like a really
senior role that you're maybe recruiting
for that gives you an opportunity to
call people that would potentially be
hiring managers but you're talking some
about job yeah yeah it's delicate
balance isn't it yeah like because we
yeah you definitely just the way it is
you have you have people that are
clients and candidates yeah and they are
on one hand calling you like chasing you
on wanting more CVS and ever handle like
if you found me right and hand me a job
yeah it's a delegate I'm gonna be
effective where a lot of people who
shared yeah so if you're not doing that
I'd also be thinking about that so look
before before we finish and I'd love to
get your thoughts on I love the way sort
you've broken down things and stuff I
guess the people that you've always seen
or being quite inspirational to you in
terms of light and billing very well
being good recruiters what what are some
of the common things have you seen these
people do you think if we think about
that what are some of the common traits
that you see in the people that you've
always sort of fought you know what
they're really leading by example yeah
yeah yeah they often just go for it they
have like I just go for it mentality hmm
my boss when I joined had like a poster
on her desk that just said just so I can
do it part of me and it's true like just
do it might find the balance between
knowing your stuff but also learning on
the on the on the phone on the meetings
so I found that the attitude of just
doing it giving yourself a mission to
make a bad call and an event a few good
ones is good really granular things like
make sure you actually meet the clients
like don't just let yourself of a phone
call find a good reason to meet them and
often that's just saying look I'm
literally five minutes away it doesn't
feel like an hour in the boardroom just
see me for 20 minutes like see your
culture firsthand and I will develop
yeah so meet people the people I know
that the most is for that they genuinely
pride themselves in being a part of
their market they're not a recruiter and
they're looking in you're at this market
they're in that market and they're a
mover and shaker in there such a
glorious look at it and that's a
different mentality or not you you're
you're in real estate that's the thing
you have to think of it because if you
don't you're never gonna have that
you're always going to feel like you're
intruding on real estate by calling
these people know that you're in real
estate and they need you yeah and I feel
part that is known
no and no no the valley that you bring
when you're in that oh yeah you're not
Vodafone calling them about their
contract sometimes you're offering this
past and the difference between a move
that can change their lives and
stagnating where they are and you have
if you don't believe it sound like that
how are they gonna believe yeah but I
believe you would have really believed
that you're worth while and like I said
earlier that doesn't mean being deluded
and working at all that obviously is a
stepping stone rollin up selling it
that's just you the way to be confident
that scenarios saying I know this isn't
we want to do long-term because I know
you
yeah so I'm not gonna lie this role is
admittedly a point A to point B type
thing yeah but I think it's worth you're
doing because you know what it will get
you there if you can if you can grind
out for two years do a good job it will
get you there yeah that is approach I'm
definitely not a very savvy person
another quality that's really good is
the best people here at least they don't
sound like they're making a sale on the
phone really it yeah like they don't it
just sounds like they're having a very
human conversation sometimes they even
say I do this I'm like maybe don't go
for it then you know what I mean maybe
maybe you know maybe just wait a little
while and we can find something better
because maybe the mark would improve him
six months so I'll call you then having
the candidates either like oh crap they
know I don't know wait six months I
bought it for it we'll all there be like
fine fair enough and they remember that
you're the one person that didn't force
them into it and that's powerful because
then when in the future you do actually
lay off ground and you're like no I
think you're making a mistake here it
counts from or til the same PA said oh I
get it last time around so yeah not
sounding like Hughes and that long-term
one said isn't it willing to take those
sort of short comings for the long-term
gain of being respected and building
credibility on yeah I think I think
that's that's a great quality of isn't
it yeah equipments the sales owner
recruiting since that recruitment I said
its sales but the best sales doesn't
sound sales it yeah you're trying to
make a sell but the best way to actually
accomplish that end is by talking to
someone like human being what yeah what
they want and just being realistic with
them my it's always to make yourself
we're here to make money I get him but I
found that rather than reading from a
script' and hard nosing it's much better
like man to man or woman here's the
thing this is probably not for you right
now in terms of your dream I don't think
your dream is attainable frankly
kind of rolls behind your dream go for
this and it will get you there in 18
months that's them
that has more sway mm how much is it
interesting from your perspective before
we finish light you've been in the
market for five and a bit years how much
has it changed from the recruitment
perspective in your experience and where
do you see it going so like what would
the sort of some of the biggest changes
that you noticed
yeah well have noticed when I joined it
was a start of it being really candidate
LED as everyone kept telling me really
like there's a candidate LED market
that's only become so much more the case
really candidates cause so much of the
shots
seriously they it's like you get an
offer these days you get an offer and
you don't even celebrate who's you've
got an offer and it's good but you're
just like the actual hurdle here is
getting this person to to hopefully
accept and yeah when they probably have
four other offers yeah that's that's a
challenge it's really candidate driven I
think I think LinkedIn is huge I think
you need to be using LinkedIn in a
really constructive way to stand out and
whether it's like you were saying like
branding or in mailing one thing I wish
I did sooner was I'm LinkedIn referrals
Nations I missed out on so many of those
like from 2015 and 16 is I just didn't
ask I've done more in the last couple of
years but I missed out some amazing ones
and that's that's your brand that's your
legacy let's do it where you were that's
them talking about you and I just wish I
did more of that so I think you have to
be ahead of the curve in technology now
whether that's LinkedIn or job boards ai
those kind of things and yet it's really
candidate driven and the main thing I
tell clients and I meet them not in like
an aggressive way I just say be aware
you guys that isn't a culture where you
can just have someone sit here in a
boardroom grill them for an hour and
they're lucky if they get called back
you've got to actually communicate the
strengths of your culture it has to be
both ways yeah and it has to be both
ways
yeah and how I know how do you say it
the next five years
anything that how do you see it sort of
evolving yeah I see I see a lot more I
see more players joining it I think
Mazzone and Google I think recruitment
is quite an unlike an immature industry
in terms of there's only a few massive
conglomerate scenarios Milo's and I
think that would change I think there's
a huge it's a very profitable business
modern I think places like Amazon and
Google and stuff we're gonna see that
we're gonna get even more saturation
more tech companies the line between
like recruitment and AI and like
automated job board recruitment if
they're gonna blur a lot and just see
things becoming more automated and I
think they'll be actually quite harmful
but I think a lot of things gonna become
automated and I just think that the role
of a recruitment company is going to be
a really interesting thing because what
we can give you is a more human than you
get by working with an Amazon or Google
on their job boards but you've got to
stay ahead there because if you're able
to if if Amazon just have a monopoly
over all of the job boards and they're
getting all of the cool things first
you've got to be competitive but I find
a way to have your own AI and serve like
I think all the tech element is huge
yeah it's gonna be interesting yeah the
next five years are gonna be really and
I think it will come down to who can be
the most technologically progressive
while also retaining that human and
inspire you're not a robot it's marrying
the - yes man or - I I couldn't agree
more my thing if you're someone that can
be absolutely brilliant yeah delivering
on the human element building
relationships being an adviser the human
element if you can really do that really
well I think that's also where a lot of
people are now not given as much time
because I think I'll just email them or
I'll just send them a message on
LinkedIn or whatever to go I mean it's I
think people were so prone to forgetting
that well actually it would actually
behind but yeah yeah so I think that's
also really interesting we're actually
sort of coming in a reverse way yeah you
can definitely achieve a lot through
online whatsapp or whatever but if you
sort of keep your eye off the if you
don't keep your eye on the ball and get
in front of people build relationships
on the phone again that that's gonna end
up being a competitive advantage you
have I think you can hide behind it and
that's another big thing the next five
years who's gonna what companies are
gonna hide behind it and alienate people
on what ones are going to use it to
enhance the moon the base stuff and
actually have it on their side and I
think hopefully we can have the Khobar
can you know
we're gonna have to because it's gonna
get even more competitive
mm so look before I'm Ashley the last
question what is Tom excited about what
what would you love to shout about so
what what is on the agenda for 2020
goodness yeah well I've uh I don't know
I'm gonna break the Tundra to Kmart this
year hopefully yeah if not more you have
more we're in a good position it's a
really encouraging January to be honest
so you're hiring for your team we are
yeah ever hiring boss to come about from
Matt leave next month oh wow yes so
she'll be back that'd be good give a bit
of structure someone to bounce ideas off
that so there's lots of positive things
are happening definitely want a great
200k obviously and get the team up there
as well almost get more satisfaction
from from doing it as a team
look at the team number yeah in like the
four of us yeah so just have it have a
great year make hay while the Sun shines
hopefully it will be shining yeah and
just crack on yeah honestly nothing
nothing profound I'm afraid final
question and if you could communicate to
every single crew out there they take on
an advice it could be a word a phrase
and they'd implement your advice
tomorrow what would you say if there was
all listening what would I say what like
a bit of advice yeah just they would all
listen they take on your advice what
comes to mind when I'll ask you that
what would you want to say to these
people if you'll I would say like if if
you're joining recruitment like I did as
a graduate then I think it may or may
not be for you hmm
but be if it isn't be the hardest
working failure in the room mmm that's
what I thought I was like when I drama
cumin I was like this might not be for
me but if it isn't I'll be able to look
myself in the mirror and be like I've
worked my absolutely awesome you know
give it a real gun exactly give it a
real go because a lot of it is out of
our hands it's beautiful isn't it but if
you can look at yourself and be like I
gave it my absolute best and I moved
with the times I kept trying that's at
least something isn't it yeah that's my
always it's really base hit but just
basically just hold on to account and
put them working
it's almost been a pleasure yes thank
you